these allegations that were put
yesterday and repeated by the right
honourable gentleman
are serious allegations and i welcome
the opportunity to come to the house
to put formally on the record that these
unsubstantiated
allegations around honesty are not true
and that i've been straight with people
in public and in private
throughout every day since i began
working
on the response to this pandemic last
january
i've got up each morning and asked what
must i do
to protect life that is the job
of a health secretary in a pandemic
we've taken
an approach of openness transparency
and explanation of both what we know and
what we don't know i was looking at it
this morning since last january i've
attended this house mr speaker
over 60 times with the prime minister
we have together hosted 84 press
conferences
i've answered 2667 contributions to this
house
and answer questions from colleagues the
media and the public
and we'll keep on with this spirit
of openness and transparency throughout
as well as coming to the house today
i'll be answering questions and hosting
another press conference
later now sometimes what we've had to
say hasn't been easy
we've had to level with people when it's
been tough when things
have been going in the wrong direction
and also
we have learned throughout we've applied
that learning
both to tackling this pandemic and
making sure that we're as well prepared
in the future
as possible but beyond all this
what matters remains the same
getting vaccinated getting tested
delivering for our country
overcoming this disease and saving lives
and that is what matters to the british
people